et
richard demarcy jean claude et bien la
bâtisse je suis ou de musique dorothée
je suis fou de musique
je sais que vous savez dans ces parce
qu'on vous a vu la semaine dernière mais
savez vous chantez home et dorothée oui
un jour je vous ferai écouter un de mes
héros favoris oui d'ailleurs de si vous
voulez je peux le faire tout de suite
non mathus nous avons un programme bien
chargé aujourd'hui à bompas de dommages
nous allons commencer donc voilà 16h24
le chevalier blanc
notre chevalier bleus sera soumis à une
épreuve très difficile c'est de
affronter une grosse salamandre oui on
va la réussite de son entreprise ne fait
aucun doute
à 16h36 vous ferez connaissance avec
notre ami céleri oui c'est un brave
lions britanniques qui cherchent un
moyen de locomotion pour partir en
vacances à 16h43 l'enfant et le sport ah
oui c'est une émission que vous
connaissez tous maintenant vous ferez
connaissance à cabourg avec une jeune
servante du tennis de table
ah oui la petite catherine ha oui elle
est très jeune mais je crois qu'elle
initie aussi des plus jeunes qu'elle a
ce sport parfois très très très
difficile à 17h11 l'époux stuff cookies
le héros de cette histoire grâce à une
fleur magique est devenu tout petit
petit petit oui ce qui lui permet de
visiter le village miniature des
boosters qui entre nous et bien alors
dimension
ah oui pardon eh bien je pense qu'après
les pouces top c'est 17h17 exactement
avec le pays de l'arc en ciel sont
aujourd'hui c'est une mine abandonnée
dentition la question et après avoir vu
un grand oui c'est une amie d'abandonner
oui je voulais parler du remorqueur de
la semaine dernière qui avait été perdu
à bien oui et aujourd'hui c'est une mine
abandonnée se passe des choses très
bizarres on veut nous verrons ça tout à
l'heure à 17h40 et une tête en friche
lui il s'agit je crois d'une famille
très historique
ah oui oui qui nous fait partager un
repas très surprenant en 1930 et à 17h49
vous aurez le petit conservatoire à huy
dong wei a très bien très bien et
n'oublions pas notre ami le docteur mais
nous allons commencer dès maintenant
avec le chevalier bleus voilà le
chevalier bleus regarde